hello and welcome to the spring 2011
edition of Rochford district matters the
information paper for the people of
Rochford district in this edition are
articles on a new wedding venue in the
area news of your council tax
information on welfare reforms how to
prepare for an emergency events around
the district and much more but to start
and with the 2012 Olympics in mind
here's an invitation to support our
stars
rochford District Council's leisure team
shop at my local and active Rochford are
working together on an exciting new
project to support our local athletes
there are many talented athletes in the
district already competing on the
international stage who need additional
support to be able to continue to excel
at the highest level local businesses
are being invited to join star at my
local which is supporting talented
athletes in Rockford as silver or bronze
sponsors sponsorship runs from april
2011 to march 2012 businesses that are
part of the shop at my local scheme have
the opportunity to support and sponsor
two very special athletes sailing
champion lucy Hodges and badminton star
Rebecca Terry the current Rochford
District sports personality of the year
Lucy won gold at both the 2010 blind
Nationals and ifds blind match race in
international championships Rebecca is
the Rochford district and Essex young
sports personality of the year and one
of the youngest players to represent
Essex at senior level active Rochford
the community active network for the
Rochford district has kick-started the
sponsorship by becoming a gold sponsor
with 1,000 pounds if you want to get
involved contact mark oldest sports
development officer on 0 1 702 31 8 121
or mark dot oldest let's al do us at
Rochford WK
telling us what you think rochford
District Council is looking for
volunteers who would like to give us
their views on the services we provide
it's a chance for you to take part and
tell us exactly what you think about a
range of issues that will help us take
decisions about desert services if
you've got an opinion and want to tell
us about it then here's how you can get
involved the group is made up of
residents who volunteer to express their
views on the council's proposals and
local services the information provided
helps the council to make its decisions
the group seeks to involve all members
of the community to ensure that the
views expressed are as representative as
possible in order for us to get the
information we need you will be asked to
fill in questionnaires take part in
telephone surveys and participate in
focus groups when signing up to take
part in the group you will be asked to
highlight any particular areas of
interest this is to ensure your views
are taken into account when relevant
consultations come up you will be
approached to get involved in
consultation throughout the year you
don't have to respond every time we just
ask that you get involved at least once
a year members are selected to get
involved according to the type of
consultation sometimes every member of
the group will be called upon sometimes
it may be only 20 people questionnaires
shouldn't take longer than 20 to 30
minutes but focus groups will take
longer the group gives you the chance to
express your opinions to the people that
make decisions you can help to represent
the views of the whole community by
bringing your ideas and viewpoints to
the group being part of the group will
be a valuable experience and is an
opportunity to give something back to
your community the consultation
exercises help the council to understand
what residents think about the issues
and as a result can help to make to help
to influence
making members will receive a regular
newsletter explaining how their views
have helped in the decision-making
program process you can sign up to the
group on the council's website at www k
forward slash have your say or you can
contact andrew lowing community planning
officer on 0170 231 8061 or andrew
lowing that's lowi ng at Rochford gov UK
raley Rochford and district association
for voluntary services ravs has a wide
range of support on offer across the
community in the Rochford district ravs
is once again running its popular laptop
courses which aim to help the over-50s
learn computing skills in a relaxed
atmosphere laptop can help you with the
beginners computer course and home
visits among the skills the course
teaches are how to visit websites that
you've seen on television how to send
emails with photos attached how to
transfer photos from cameras to
computers and print them out how to
learn about internet shopping revs is
also offering free courses aimed at
helping people aged 19 and over who are
unemployed hoping to return to work or
who do not have any formal
qualifications to find employment or
further training courses include CV
writing interview skills online job
searching and basic computer skills
they're being delivered by ravs under
contract with Essex County Council adult
community learning and funded by the
skills funding agency the sessions take
place on Saturday and Monday mornings
until the end of June 2011 excluding
public and bank holidays from ten a.m.
to 1pm at Rochford parish council parish
rooms West Street Rochford SS 41 AAS and
if you want to learn laptop contact ravs
on 01 268 double 727 96 or email them
ravs that's double our AVS at ravs org
dot u K and ravs news in brief over
Christmas ravs once again organized its
annual families in need appeal to
support local families and children in
the Rockford district with food parcels
and presence more than 70 parcels of
food and goodies were distributed to
families across the district
to help make Christmas special for them
at least two hundred and ten children
were helped by the appeal this year
perhaps was helped in the annual appeal
with continued generous support from
local churches rotary and lions clubs
and donations from other organizations
and individuals
the rayleigh windmill is now licensed
for weddings naming ceremonies and
renewal of vows the windmill was built
in 1809 and thrived in the early 19th
century set in the heart of historic
rayleigh the windmill has been
sympathetically refurbished to allow the
continued enjoyment and use of the venue
it is located next to the sensory garden
and historic Raley mount owned and
managed by the National Trust a perfect
backdrop for your pictures Raley has a
host of venues for receptions and other
items to help make your day extra
special including florists jewelers
formal wedding attire and decorations
with seating for up to 20 guests Raley
windmill offers an intimate venue for
your civil wedding civil partnership
naming ceremony or renewal of vows
several packages are available including
the option to hold your reception at the
mill Arts & Events Center adjacent to
the windmill the services of a dedicated
event coordinator are at your disposal
to ensure that your special day runs
perfectly to arrange a viewing or to
discuss your specific requirements
please contact watch for District
Council on 0 1 702 318 120 or 0 17025
463 double 6 extension 3619 or visit w
WR OTE govt UK forward slash weddings
once again the rayleigh windmill has
achieved the accreditation of quality
assured visitor attraction from visit
england this is the second year in a row
that the windmill has received this
recognition and a call for volunteers
the windmill would not be as successful
or popular as it is today without the
support and generosity of its volunteers
we are always looking for more people to
become involved in the windmill for more
information on events at the windmill
details on how to get involved in
volunteering or exhibitions at the
windmill contact the lazer team on 0170
25 463 double six or email leisure at
Rochford
dot uk'